let's go to voicemail voicemail number
two one nine to david p here is a
voicemail that came in take a listen to
this hey David I want to know your
thoughts on HIV no longer being a felony
in California and just all the people
that this is going to affect I mean AIDS
is an epidemic so I don't know I just
think it's crazy this is a case of being
too progressive going to hurt gay
people's No
okay so we're gonna talk about that on
the bonus show today California has
lowered the penalty for knowingly
exposing partners to HIV from a felony
to a misdemeanor and we're going to talk
about that on today's bonus show we will
also talk about the new study that says
there is enough wind energy over the
Earth's oceans to power all of human
civilization but can you practically
implement that we will talk about that
will also to also talk about FIFA fining
Germany for Nazi chance at a World Cup
qualifier all of those stories and more
on the bonus show you can sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership i am
speaking publicly public speaking event
thursday october twelfth 10:00 a.m. at
Worcester State University I don't
remember the name of exactly what
building it's happening in but if you
google david pakman Worcester State
University October 12 it will come up
the event is open to the public I will
be speaking about fake news
critical-thinking media literacy and
climate change there will be time for
audience questions very very exciting
stuff hope you can join me there google
that sign up david pakman.com slash
membership you can also get access to
the bonus show through patreon by making
a $5 pledge $5 at patreon.com slash
david pakman show